you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're just able to
foster kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
pick everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation little cuz heroes fly well
you hear your fake family to stand up
for you hey man sorry about that
daily bats I choose you
escape you
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your names
through sure Sam are you for real
okay Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah it's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing I get the feeling super
straight just pin you fly if I quit your
we know I still okay why are you talking
you know I don't think it's gonna buff
out your bum stars your phone charged
like a bad guy right
you have full immunity from your dead
sorry about your window you're welcome
for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
you